-A judge ruled on Friday
that Donald Trump
will remain in contempt of court
after failing to comply
with a subpoena
in a fraud investigation.
As more bombshell
text messages emerged
implicating more GOP
members of Congress
in the attempted coup
on January sixth.
Also, Trump endorsed
a nonexistent person
for Senate in Ohio.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
As we have established
for a long time now.
One of the things Trump did
to the modern GOP
is he weird-ified it.
He unleashed his army of Mafia
bobblehead goons and freaks.
And now the Republican Party is
an institution
just filled with weirdos
obsessed with things
like cocaine fueled orgies,
Disney erotica
and testicle tanning.
An example of one
of those weirdos
is his former personal attorney
and neck-less
wonder Rudy Giuliani.
Now, we have shown you clips
over the years of Rudy Giuliani
saying and doing many
bizarre things.
But I have to say this latest
might be the weirdest yet.
Rudy is on Cameo where you can
pay him to say things.
And to advertise that fact,
he posted
this video online today.
-I'm Rudy Giuliani.
If you want to have
a really nice conversation
or a birthday greeting
or just talk golf
go to the link below.
-This is the weirdest metronome
I have ever seen.
It does not even look.
I'm sorry.
It doesn't even look like
an actual human body.
It looks like one
of Jeff Dunham's puppets.
It's like a like a windup toy
you get in a giveaway bag
at a mobster's funeral.
Is this from his new movie
"Weekend at Rudy's"?
Why is he just flaccidly
swinging the club back and forth
like a wet pool noodle
the entire time?
Is he trying to hypnotize us?
I'm not wasting money on Cameo.
Or will I get Cameo?
It looks like one of
those drinking birds.
if instead of water,
all it drank with scotch.
So it's a party of weirdos
led by head weirdo Donald Trump
who keeps going
around the country,
reminding us of
his relentless weirdness.
For example,
it has been well documented,
including on this show,
that Trump has
an obsession with toilets.
He has a whole platform
ranting about toilets
not flushing due
to low water pressure.
And even now,
amid a deadly plague
and a land war in Europe,
it's still one of the staples
of his rallies speeches.
Trump repeated it again
during a rally in Ohio
just over a week ago.
-You ever go into a new home
and you turn on the faucet
and there's no water comes out.
So you're sitting there
washing your hands.
It'll come on water.
Come out, baby.
Same thing with showers.
I'd go into a shower
and I'd go to a hotel
that was new and I said,
"I can't stay in these places."
Why?
The water just drips out
a little bit slowly.
And I won't talk about the third
element of the bathroom,
because every time I do,
the fake news
only talks about that.
But you know what I'm talking
about one time,
two times, five times,
ten times, no water comes out.
-I love that he used to be
the leader of the free world
and now he sounds like
an all caps post on Next Door.
"I flush one, two, three times.
No water comes out.
Also, have you seen this cat?"
And by the way,
it is not normal that we know
his position on toilets.
Biden has been president
for over a year.
I have no idea
where he stands on toilets.
I mean, I assume he's pro.
Also,
I like the Trump thinks
as long as he doesn't
say the word toilet.
The fake news won't know
what he's talking about.
Like our minds are blown when
he calls it the third element.
Like it's a canceled
sci-fi series.
Although it would be amazing
if Trumpers started calling it
the third element.
It would save you trouble if you
were ever at a family reunion,
and some distant cousin
was like,
Hey, I got to go hit
the third element.
But when we get back, we're
going to start talking politics.
You could be in your car
before he even flushed.
Now there is a chance
Trump's obsession with toilets
and their inability to flush
has something to do
with the fact that he reportedly
has a habit of destroying
documents via a toilet.
While President Trump
was in office,
staff in the White House
residence
periodically discovered wads of
printed paper clogging a toilet
and believed the president
had flushed pieces of paper.
Either he was destroying
official documents
by flushing them
or using official documents
as toilet paper.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, man, there's no paper.
Mel!
Mel, there's no paper.
Can you slide
the daily briefing in, Mel?
Mel, This is the prenup.
You want me to amend it?
[ Normal voice ]
If you want a toilet that can
handle official documents,
you need one of those high
powered super flushers
they have on airplanes.
You ever seen one
of those toilets get clogged?
No. They can handle anything.
Because the people
who designed those toilets
knew what they were up against.
A plane full of people
who had breakfast
and stopped at the airport bar,
then got a Cinnabon and then ate
a vintage Salisbury steak
in severe turbulence.
Those toilets are ready to go.
You could put a toaster in there
and flush it without a problem.
Anyway, the point
of all of this.
If there can even be a point.
Is that Trump has a troubled
history
with document preservation,
and that troubled history
is now costing him
after a judge ruled on Friday
that he's still
in contempt of court
for failing to turn
over documents
Trump claims he doesn't have.
-Breaking news out of New York
where former President
Donald Trump
is now being held
in contempt of court
for refusing to comply
with a subpoena
as part of the New York AG's
investigation into his company.
-A Manhattan judge rejecting
former President Trump's appeal,
denying his lawyers request to
lift a contempt of court order
despite the former president
submitting an affidavit
that he just can't find the
documents they're looking for.
This comes just three days after
that contempt order kicked in,
which would fine Mr. Trump
$10,000 each day
until he coughs up
the related documents.
-First of all, it doesn't
surprise me at all
that Trump says he can't find
the documents they want.
And then the Trump organization
didn't have actual files.
I doubt they even recorded
any of their meetings.
When you get a Google calendar
invite from
the Trump Organization,
it probably just says
subject the thing,
location the place,
attendees the guys.
So Trump is now been held
in contempt
as part of a fraud investigation
in which he claims
he doesn't have the documents
that have been subpoenaed.
And if you ask me,
there's a decent chance
the reason he doesn't have them
is he flush them
down the toilet.
This is the guy.
This is the guy the Republican
Party is in lockstep behind.
Just consider how humiliating it
must be to grovel
for the toilet
weirdos endorsement,
which Republicans across
the country have been doing.
Like Senate candidate
J.D. Vance in Ohio,
Vance spent years relentlessly
criticizing Trump,
and now he has
to debase himself
by taking back
all those criticisms
in order to earn
Trump's endorsement.
And Trump has returned
Vance's loyalty
by refusing to even
remember his name.
-Author and former venture
capitalist J.D. Vance
desperately sought
and earned
the endorsement from former
President Trump over Ohio's
former state treasurer
Josh Mandel.
Although for a moment overnight,
it wasn't clear to anyone,
apparently even Trump,
exactly who he endorsed.
-You know,
we've endorsed Dr. Oz.
We've endorsed
J.P., right J.D. Mandel,
and he's doing great.
They're all doing good.
-I mean, it's pretty remarkable
that we've endorsed Dr. Oz.
Isn't even the craziest sentence
in that clip.
This guy can't even be bothered
to remember the names
of the people he's endorsing, he
went from J.P. to J.D. Mandel.
If you kept talking, he would
have endorsed J.K. Rowling.
[ As Trump ]
We endorse J.P., J.D., you know,
the famous the famous writer,
J.K. Rowling,
the author of
"Harry Potter
and The Third Element."
[ Normal voice ]
This is how much you have to
forfeit your dignity to succeed
in today's Republican Party.
You have to grovel
and debase yourself
to earn the endorsement of a guy
who can't even
remember your name.
A toilet obsessed weirdo who
in the same speech once again
bragged about acing
that stupid dementia test
where you have to identify some
animals on a piece of paper.
-I said, "How tough is this
test, Ronnie?
Because these people are calling
me bad names,
they're calling me stupid.
They're stupid, Ronnie.
And we got to end this [bleep]."
So I said, "How long
and how tough is the test?"
They said, "Well,
the first questions are easy,
but when you get to the middle
of the tests, they're very hard.
-Yeah, they're very hard.
For example,
you have to remember the names
of people you have endorsed.
That's how smart people
pronounce it, though, "stoopid."
Let me just remind you, all,
in case you've forgotten,
and I hope you have that
none of the questions are hard.
There's a part of the test where
you have to name a few animals.
And judging from his inability
to remember human names,
I can't imagine Trump aced it.
I'm guessing he wrote down,
I don't know for this one...
and probably called this one...
This, this is the guy
for whom the Republican Party
tried to overthrow democracy.
Every day we get more evidence
implicating more and more
Republicans
in the attempted coup.
Republican members of Congress
were secretly texting
and hatching schemes to keep
Trump in power.
As the AP reported over
the weekend,
there's mounting evidence
of GOP involvement
in Trump's election schemes.
That includes people like Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan,
who was texting with Trump's
chief of staff, Mark Meadows.
Just hours before the mob
stormed the Capitol,
Jordan offered a legal rationale
for what Trump was publicly
demanding that
Vice President Mike Pence,
in his ceremonial role,
presiding over
the electoral count,
somehow assert the authority
to reject electors
from Biden won states.
Pence should call out
all electoral votes
that he believes
are unconstitutional
as no electoral votes at all,
Jordan wrote.
You don't get to just
throw out votes
you believe
are unconstitutional.
Believing doesn't make it so.
It's not a Disney movie,
"Dumbo, you can fly.
You have to believe.
Just don't look down."
-Below!
-But...
[ Laughter ]
I would,
I would've liked to hear
Trump try to thank Jim Jordan
for his loyalty.
[ As Trump ] I just want to
thank my close friend and ally,
the great congressman
from Ohio, Jim Jarmusch.
Jimmy, we love his movies
though over coffee and cigarets.
And that was today's...
[ Music plays ]
In addition...[Laughs]
[ Laughter ]
In addition to being a party of
aspiring authoritarians hellbent
on dismantling democracy,
the Republican Party
is just filled with weirdos.
Their standard bearer is a guy
whose main obsession is toilets,
specifically,
toilets that aren't
strong enough to handle
all his --
-[bleep]
-This has been A Closer Look.
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.